Godzilla there's a character with a big
sort of history isn't it so does it feel
like a big challenge for you coming as a
director the second feature film isn't
it to take that on and how does it feel
like do you think how do you imagine it
will feel like kind of dealing with fans
and that sort of thing on that um we
dealt with fans to an extent on the
first one like as in when I say fans I
don't mean we had loads of people who
liked the movie I've had people who
didn't like the movie who I thought
would he were that like you know come to
things like this and um I know that you
can really do something constantly
worrying about what everyone else is
going to think like that that way lies a
bad film I think you've got to do what
you believe would be a really great
experience sitting watch that's all you
can ever really do and then yeah and I
think it's like even though I'd say all
films are not created equally but
they're all received equally which is
your you sit down in a cinema for about
two hours and what if the film cost 10p
or it costs 200 million it you still
have to sit down in a room when it
lights go out and you sit and you watch
this experience and so and that's what
I'm concentrating on like when I'm
picturing stuff I don't the rest it's
just the details it's really like what
would it be like to sit and watch this
moment and how would it feel and is it
the right choice and how it feel if I
did something different and you're just
experimenting in your mind the whole
time about that moment a year or two
years out where you're going to be
sitting there watching something and and
so that's all I have a picture and that
that whatever kind of film you make
however you make it that's identical
like like that's that's never going to
be different so yeah I mean so that I
just worry about that I don't worry
about the process in terms of
it's always going to be different
hopefully fingers crossed I hope it'd be
fantastic if you had a career where you
never made a film that exactly the same
way you made a previous one because then
it'd start to be stale for you wouldn't
in and technology is moving at such a
pace and the industry is changing so
much you know to an extent that there's
a chance that could happen like that
every film if you make another film
every film could could have a totally
different way about you know something
very unique about it that infects them
the film itself and hopefully makes
something a bit different to what you've
done before because if you just repeat
in yourself like the process of thing is
as much as is important to the outcome
of the film as has anything and like
monsters the reason it looked and felt
the way it did for better or for worse
was because of the process we did it
under which was very opportunistic
ad-libbing kind of cheap and and it it
has a vibe about it that if you didn't
have that process you wouldn't get that
kind of film necessarily how does it
feel stepping up in terms of budgets
that you have to work on a feature is it
kind of something that's bit daunting
would you put it to the back of your
mind I don't think it strange but it's
like I relate it to being a kid and I
remember being a kid and wanting sweets
all the time and suites were like two
and three P and then one day asking my
mom like how much money she earned and I
can try but it was but it was like
unfathomable amount of money I was
thinking when I'm an adult I'm gonna buy
every single suite in the whole shop you
know I mean it was just and you become
an adult and you don't go and buy every
suite in the whole shop just your Suites
become or what you know equivalent of
sweets become more expensive and so it's
just like that like the budget gets
bigger but the things you're spending
you know it on get bigger and it's sort
of all it doesn't didn't feel that
different you know I mean I know it's
not even it's not something that's
really my it's not my job to be that
worried about because I'm not the
producers
so I'm just got to try met the best film
possible and that's someone else's job
to worry about the number crunching so
yeah you try if I really thought about
it I you know you'd paralyze yourself
you know so you have to just park call
them well we're looking forward to
seeing I'm zilla definitely say lots of
luck with that but just finally when you
when you've got through Godzilla and
we've seen it and we've all lived it i'm
sure we will do what would you like to
be doing next in an ideal world um if
thats yeah so I mean as a sci-fi movie
that was wanted to do that's all with
tmobile mabait of and and I would
inevitably think that I'd do that
afterwards maybe however it worked out I
mean this is the thing is you just you
can't plan too far ahead like the idea I
won't want to plan beyond another film
because it's a bit cocky you know you
just I just want to make the next thing
the best thing possible and then see
where you're at after that and reassess
and make another choice and I don't
think you can be too clever about this
stuff because it's changing like your
situation changes and you know what I
thought I'd be doing at what age I'd be
doing it it's so different to what's
happened so just given up trying to be
too clever and just take each scenario
as it comes
you